Let's take another example to
now start building the kinds of
curves that we're interested
in from real data.
Just to keep things simple,
rather than use my stack of real images,
I'm just going to showcase these small
types of ramp gray scale images here.
And I've basically have, kind of
simulated them to have a shutter speed
of 1/64, darker image, 1/16,
1/4, 1 sec and 4 secs.
It gets from darker to brighter.
Again, we're interested in getting to I,
the intensities.
G is my function, and
the thing that we want to extract
from is exposure H, right?
I mean that is the relationship,
because remember the rest of it
we actually were able to get
to from the camera itself.
So now to get an exposure basically
we would base, have to compute
the irradiance, E, and with the time and
we know all of this of course.
We can also do this in log because
that actually makes our curves and
everything appear nice.
And of course just,
I'm showing these pixel values here.
And I'm going to basically create
an axis, the log of an exposure H.
What we can do now is find, let's say,
three points, one, two and three here.
At three different points,
I've colored them differently so
we can see where they are.
And of course I now in this instance can
pick out what their values would be.
Similarly now I can find three
similar exact points in another image.
And I'm actually just randomly
walking around in these five images.
And if you notice that basically
I can find these three
points in all of these images.
You know how to get these images,
feature tracking and
feature detection work, or
feature matching work that we looked at
allows you to find these types
of things in a real image.
This is just a synthetic test
case that I'm showing you.
Of course, after I find these points,
I can actually use this
to plot these values.
Of course, I'm showing this purple here.
While I just have five images here,
you can imagine I may have more.
And this would allow me to get
a bunch of different values here.
So here you have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, and so on.
This allows me to kind of,
you know, blot these out.
I can do the same for turquoise.
And here is the range change
that's happening in this one.
Pixel values, log of Exposure.
Based on this calculations again,
pure data.
And in case of the yellow, basically
we see this kind of phenomenon.
Where basically again we
have points like this.
So I took a lot of samples, over ten
plus, and this is what it gave me.